do you know your lros from your elrond
and your har foots from your hobbits
some people do and if you don't you soon
will from the unseen lands of numenor to
the veils of anduin these are things
only true fans notice in the trailer for
the lord of the rings the rings of power
one of the first images that amazon
released for the show way back in august
of 2021 was a gorgeous still with a
figure in the foreground a city not far
away and light emanating from a low
point on the distant horizon at that
point everyone and their mother guessed
that what we were seeing was a not so
subtle easter egg of the two trees of
valinor this time we get a close-up that
leaves no room for speculation as the
clip begins morvid clark's galadriel can
be heard narrating she starts by
referencing the past speaking about an
age before the sunrise but it didn't
mean the world was in darkness
but even then
there was light at this point we see a
close-up of two gigantic glowing trees
one is the gold-colored laurelin and the
other is the silverish white telparion
these two hollowed living light posts
provided light to the world for a long
time early in middle-earth history they
aren't the only source of light but
they're pretty nearly so when they're
destroyed at the end of the years of the
trees they deliver two fruits before
they fully perish these become you
guessed it the sun and the moon
not far into the trailer there is a
series of sweeping clips that show off
some stunning middle-earth landscapes we
see two lines of tiny individuals elves
maybe who move across the screen the
last clip shows the column high up on a
mountainside walking through the snow
about to cross through a gap in the
mountainous peaks as the camera pans
beyond them and sweeps through the pass
a bird flies into the distance at first
it just looks like any airborne foul but
upon further investigation and when
compared against the mighty backdrop of
the mountains this bird turns out to not
be any ordinary creature it appears to
be enormous could it be an eagle the
eagles of middle earth are famous they
save gandalf bilbo and their dwarven
companions when they escape from the
misty mountains in the hobbit they also
show up at the end of that story as a
last-minute happy ending when they save
the day at the battle of the five armies
then their chief saves gandalf from
orthanc in the fellowship of the ring
and they arrive in the nick of time at
the battle before the black gates in the
return of the king suffice it to say
they are a consistent presence
throughout the stories that we already
know and love but the history of the
eagles isn't limited to the third age it
goes back practically to the beginning
of time they're created along with the
ants to help protect the land and they
serve the spiritual guardians of middle
earth called the valar the fact that
we've already seen an eagle this early
is interesting maybe they'll have a
bigger part to play in rings of power
than anyone initially expected
several portions of the trailer are
filled with quick shots that provide
little glimpses of different
middle-earth dwellings one of these
shows a gorgeous glimpse of a stronghold
that looks very similar to rivendell
it's an elven looking city with tall
slender buildings clustered onto a range
of tall mountains or hills while the
optics look similar though there's no
way it's rivendell why because elrond's
peaceful fortress doesn't exist when the
rings of power story begins what's more
likely is that this is a city in the
elven area called lindon there gilgalad
is king and elrond operates as his
right-hand man before he branches off on
his own immediately after this shot we
get a stunning second or two of what has
to be moria if the words stunning and
morya sound wrong in the same sentence
let us remind you that the ill-fated
minds weren't always home to corpses and
balrogs the word moria means the black
pit and it's used to describe the
subterranean kingdom after it gets
thrashed in the era of the rings of
power the area is called khazad doom and
it's referred to as a dwarven mansion
one that is teeming with life and light
no less we see the underground kingdom
at multiple points throughout the
trailer and it certainly looks like
better real estate than in the lord of
the rings
midway through the trailer galadriel is
shown being encouraged by multiple
people to stop fighting one elf tells
her she's fought long enough another
tells her to put up her sword the second
pointy-eared fellow is none other than
elrond himself played here by robert
aramaio the two verbally spar over the
pacifistic remark with galadriel
claiming elrond hasn't seen what she has
seen the latter responds that he has
seen his share while galadriel ends up
playing a trump card on elrond's past
experiences a moment later the half
elven hero isn't blowing smoke even by
this early point in his life elrond has
seen some pretty rough stuff when he is
just six years old he's a victim of an
elven civil war called the third
kinsling the future leader of rivendell
and his twin brother elros are spared
amidst the carnage but even then they
think their mother has committed suicide
by jumping into the ocean rather than
being captured by her attackers while
this does give elrond some serious past
experiences it pales in comparison to
galadriel's trials and tribulations
still it's an interesting point that
elrond does have some past scars some of
which he obtains as a very young elf
when elrond mentions that he's seen his
share of fire and slaughter galadriel
immediately one-ups him by pointing out
that her experiences far exceed his you
have not seen what i've seen the line is
interrupted by a horrifying shot to
paint a discomforting word picture we
see what appears to be a scene filmed
from an underwater perspective dead and
impaled bodies are floating everywhere
all set against a fire red backdrop as
buildings burn up above the surface the
harrowing scene in question isn't made
clear however there is one immediate
guess in our minds the first kin slang
also known as the kinslang at aqualande
this horrifying event takes place just
before the first age of middle-earth
begins it involves a faction of the
headstrong group of elves called the
noldor led by their intractable leader
feyenoor who attack and murder a bunch
of their fellow elves to steal their
vessels and sail back to middle earth
it's a tragic part of middle earth
history and it's something that
galadriel witnesses firsthand in the
book unfinished tales tolkien tells us
that galadriel fought fiercely against
feyenoor in defense of her mother's kin
of course just because she chose the
right side doesn't mean she wasn't
scarred by the ordeal and that's just
one of several acutely distressing past
events that are likely to fuel this
passionate character when the rings of
power story begins
at one point in the trailer the high
king gilgalad can be seen speaking words
of ill omen darkness will march over the
face of the earth it will be the end not
just of our people but all peoples as
these foreboding words are uttered the
shot flits from the king to his trusted
lieutenant elrond who is shown suddenly
looking back over his shoulder with
concern written on his face at that
moment we get a split second of the
setting behind the young elf and it's
worth a closer look the nighttime scene
is dark but there is enough light to see
that away in the distance two steep
mountain ranges can be seen they rise up
sharply and both have a cluster of
lights at their feet in between the
ranges is the inky blackness of a sea
this gives the appearance of an inlet of
water nestled between two peaks if this
is the case this could very easily be a
shot of the grey havens and its
surrounding geography we're talking
about the port area where frodo and
bilbo set sail at the end of the return
of the king located in northwestern
middle earth just left of the shire
these havens are ancient by the time we
see them in the lord of the rings if
this is indeed them they aren't the
ancient elvish haven we're used to
seeing they would be fairly new at this
point as they were established right at
the beginning of the second age not long
before the rings of power story begins
the trailer gives us more footage of a
shot that was already seen in an earlier
teaser in which galadriel and a group of
elvish companions set sail in a
swan-shaped boat to an unknown
destination in the previous footage and
again in this trailer we see the boat
sailing in darker waters toward a steady
sustained light away in the distance the
initial reaction was that this location
was either the blessed realm away in the
west or the island of numenor after
taking in the new footage it's still
difficult to make a decision but we're
starting to believe that it's the
blessed realm thanks to another shot
that takes place right after the boat is
shown again here galadriel is depicted
in a blaze of light that seems to be
coming horizontally from the left could
it be the sun sure but the orientation
of the boat seems to be pointed west
which would make it a setting sun if
that's the case the brightness of the
hues seems too yellowy to be the end of
the day instead the light seems to be
coming from somewhere could it be the
blessed realm if so unless it's a
flashback the light can't be coming from
the two trees as they're long gone by
the time of rings of power could
goladriel be facing someone like varda
the queen of the valar varda is
brilliantly described in the
silmarillion that tome says too great is
her beauty to be declared in the words
of men or of elves for the light of a
louvitar live still in her face in light
is her power and her joy it's a wild
guess but it just might be possible the
marketing for the dwarves and rings of
power has thus far been focused on two
distinct characters prince durin iv and
princess diesel both seem likely to
figure prominently in the story but
prince durin is just a prince for a
reason presumably his father during the
third is still the king of khazad doom
at this point although we haven't heard
much about the venerable leader in the
trailer we finally see a character who
appears to be the dwarven king as played
by peter mullen he speaks to an unknown
figure i am sorry
but their time has come then the camera
cuts away while it's difficult to guess
what the royal figure is talking about
it's fun to think that we've finally
seen the leader of a rich and thriving
cause of doom during the third is likely
to play a pretty crucial role even if
it's largely seen through the eyes of
his princely sun according to the source
material during the third is the first
dwarf to get one of the rings of power
and according to dwarven legend he is
given it by the elven lord and craftsman
kelebrimbor not sauron while that last
part is likely untrue it doesn't change
the fact that we should see quite a bit
more of during the third as the rings of
power story plays out
the second teaser finally provided some
images of the critically important
island nation of numenor however this
latest trailer shed some significant
light on the island people specifically
focusing on several members of their
royal line at different points
throughout the second half of the teaser
we see multiple numenoreans who based on
the source material will play critical
roles as both antagonist and
protagonists throughout the story at one
point we see a flash of a young figure
on board a ship the character is a young
isildur played by maxim baldry a moment
later we see isildor's famous father
elendil played by lloyd owen the pair
are key figures in aragorn's family tree
and are members of an offshoot of the
royal house of numenor which is why they
can claim the kingships of arnor and
gondor later in the story we also see a
longer clip of the royal family member
muriel as played by cynthia adai
robinson the queen regent is directly in
line for the throne of numenor both in
the show and the source material she
should factor in as a protagonist
although some earlier versions of
tolkien's writings did spin her as one
of the bad guys finally we get a shot of
another cousin of the royal house
pharazone played by tristan gravel he is
a major antagonist in the story and it
appears that his power hungry character
starts off already riling the masses
after many narrative moments focused on
the past we finally get some positive
forward thinking words from none other
than prince during the fourth the
dwarven prince is shown holding up
something small and shiny this could be
the beginning of a new era while nothing
is explicitly stated we're willing to
guess that he's talking about mithril
mithril is an extremely rare metal from
middle earth in the fellowship of the
ring gandalf explains that the wealth of
moria was not in gold and jewels the
toys of the dwarves nor in iron their
servant he goes on a bit later to say
that the wealth of the subterranean
kingdom came from maurya silver mithril
he adds that all folk desire it it could
be beaten like copper and polished like
glass and the dwarves could make of it a
metal light and yet harder than tempered
steel methril is the number one
commodity for moria if only because it's
the only place in middle earth where the
precious stuff can be found it's the
greedy mining for more mithril that
eventually wakes up the balrog but that
happens much later than the rings of
power narrative well into the third age
before that time it is a source of
immeasurable wealth for the dwarves and
we may be witnessing the realization of
that truth in this clip
kelle brimbore is one of the key
characters in the rings of power story
this is the guy who learns to make the
actual rings of power thanks in part to
the help of a cleverly disguised sauron
eventually calibrimbor learns his
mistake and pays a serious price for
being duped by the dark lord when the
story starts though kelebrimbor is still
a highly respected elven lord with an
impeccable pedigree his family
credentials go straight back to
feyenoord the infamously hot-headed
elven ancestor may have a serious anger
issue but he's also hands down the best
craftsman in all of middle earth history
his grandson caleb brimbore inherits his
skills even if he rejects his
grandfather's darker sins kelebrimbor is
a masterful craftsman and in the source
material he assembles a group of smiths
known as the gwythe mirdine these fellow
craftsmen form a brotherhood that up
until now we haven't heard anything
about toward the end of the trailer we
see a shot of several elven individuals
drawing their swords as if in a ceremony
the timing here is important as the
brief scene comes just after during the
fourth holds up what looks like a piece
of methril the guaithy mirdine set up
shop next to maria to be near the
precious metals so they could import it
for their craft work the timing of the
two moments could mean we're seeing that
group of smiths for the first time the
other possibility here could relate to
feyenoord himself as the elven patriarch
is famous for having his sons swear a
terrible oath perhaps the scene is
depicting that oath in action the man in
the fire has been around since the first
marketing teaser was dropped during the
super bowl the character looks like an
old male human who arrives in a meteor
and he has been shown repeatedly
engulfed in a crater of flames even
though he isn't burning speculation of
who this mysterious figure is has run
rampant since day one and this latest
trailer only adds fuel to the fire one
of the last things we see is the fiery
pit with the man inside along with one
of the harfoots likely nori brandyfoot
he's shown grabbing the ground and then
many of the surrounding rocks begin to
levitate around him then the fire
quickly disappears and the scene cuts
away but just before that happens we see
something the clip is shown from above
for a brief second the figure is in the
center and flames spread outward from
him they make a shape a shape that's
very easy to recognize it looks like a
flaming eye if this isn't a reference to
sauron we don't know what is the idea
that the man is sauron is possible as
the future dark lord does have a bit of
a slow nearly repentant start to the
second age but it could very easily be a
misdirect perhaps this is a proto form
of the eye symbol before it's inherited
by the dark lord it's a mystery that is
only growing as the premiere approaches
the last shot of the trailer follows a
quartet of harfoots as they make their
way down a rolling green slope the
scenery is idyllic iconic middle-earth
stuff some trees can be seen here and
there but by and large the overall feel
is one of hilly rolling grasslands it
feels an awful lot like the veils of
anduin the name of a sprawling area of
middle-earth just east of the northern
misty mountains this is an area that
sees a lot of action over the long years
of middle earth's history many men live
there and elves and dwarves crisscross
it at different points later on bjorn
the skin changer's house is located in
the area as is radagast's home on the
edge of merckwood there's one other
group that lives here for a long while
before they migrate westward too hobbits
earlier groups of hobbit ancestors spend
a long while living in the area the
prologue of the fellowship of the ring
even says their earliest tales seem to
glimpse a time when they dwelt in the
upper veils of anduin between the eaves
of greenwood the great and the misty
mountains could this be the very
beginning of that slow migration into
the veils of anduin there's one thing
that makes this particularly interested
in the theory the mountains away in the
distance of the shot a very long line of
peaks can be seen could this be the
misty mountains to the west with the
eaves of greenwood the great which is
also called mirkwood behind them in the
east it's possible but as with many of
these details only time will shed more
light on the mystery
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the lord of the rings are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]